From more murderous games we never got to
see, to alternate costumes, characters, and
casting, Squid Game was almost completely
different!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan, and
in this video I'm revealing everything that
was deleted, cut or changed in the final version
of Squid Game.
Obviously, spoilers ahead, so take care.
When the show's creator first came up with
the concept for Squid Game back in 2008, he
wanted to make a feature-length movie, not
a TV series.
The original script was for a two-hour film
and although it mainly concentrated on the
games, rather than the relationships between
characters and their backstories, there still
wasn't enough screen-time to cover all the
games we see in the show today.
In fact, even when it came to the Netflix
series, there were still a whole bunch of
Korean children's games they considered including
but that ended up getting the chop.
For instance, there was Gonggi, which consists
of throwing into the air, catching, and picking
up pebbles or other small objects.
Not only is it popular in Korea, but it's
also found in countries around the world,
under a variety of names including knucklebones
or jacks.
Another game the creator almost included but
decided to cut was a game based on a Korean
nursery rhyme that's similar to Oranges And
Lemons or London Bridge Is Falling Down, where
children form arches or gates with their arms
which they drop to catch players walking underneath
as the song finishes.
I can imagine the horrific twist that the
show might have added to this game, given
how the nursery rhyme ending of Oranges and
Lemons is a chopper coming to chop off your
head.
A team game that almost made it into the series
was "Why Did You Come To My House?", where
players hold hands in two lines and advance
on each other, trying to win players from
the other side over to their own.
It's a bit like the game Red Rover but the
Korean version also involves a song and Rock
Paper Scissors.
Originally, instead of the red and blue tile
game the Salesman plays with Gi-hun, the show's
creator thought they should play a kind of
knitting game called "Cat's Cradle".
It's a game where players create string figures
between their fingers and he thought it would
be funny to see two men doing that.
However, he said he gave up on the idea as
"the rules [wouldn't] be understood globally".
Elastics or Jump Rope was also suggested,
but he felt that didn't work "in terms of
excitement and tension" and "was a little
difficult for everyone" when it came to explaining
all the rules.
By the way, Gonggi and Elastics did at least
get a shout-out in the show when Gi-hun was
speculating what game they might play next.
The distinctive costumes worn by the characters
are a crucial part of the highly stylised
series.
But, originally, its creator wanted a completely
different look for the games' workers which
would have given them more of a Boy Scout
vibe.
Now, I can see where he was coming from with
that idea as boy scouts are associated with
childhood and the whole show from its games
to its sets emphasises the irony of grown-ups
playing kids' games but with very adult consequences.
However, Scout outfits wouldn't have given
the workers the same degree of anonymity.
And they also wouldn't have given them the
sense of being "ants in an ant colony" that
the director was looking for.
The show's art director also went through
numerous takes on the workers' masks, including
animal designs, before arriving at the final
fencing-inspired mask with lines reminiscent
of an ant's face.
The ultimate design of hot-pink hooded jumpsuits
with black masks has proven hugely popular
around the world, with store-bought versions
selling like hot cakes, or should that be
honeycombs?
And becoming a top choice for Halloween.
Some of the most heart-breaking moments in
the marbles game were originally going to
be very different.
In the early days of Squid Game's development
as a movie, Ji-yeong as we know her didn't
exist and, rather than a young woman who'd
been imprisoned for killing her abusive father,
in her place was a male character.
However, ten years later, when writer-director
Hwang Dong-hyuk came to adapt his original
idea for TV,
he decided to create a female character instead
as he wanted to develop a bond between her
and North Korean defector Sae-byeok, and highlight
two people who weren't fighting and killing
each other to climb up despite their gut-wrenching
life-or-death situation.
The scenes between Ji-yeong and her partner
in the marbles game, with all their empathy
and understanding, are among the most powerful
and touching moments in the series and have
had viewers the world over in tears.
In fact, just reading the script for that
episode had the actress who played Sae-byeok
sobbing her heart out.
And as far as the show's creator is concerned,
those two characters are, in a way, the 'most
innocent people' and Ji-yeong sacrificing
herself so Sae-byeok can reunite her family
is the 'scene that makes you cry the most'.
Another fan favourite performance we almost
missed out on was Anupam Tripathi's portrayal
of Pakistani migrant worker Ali Abdul, who
ends up in the games as he can't support his
family after his boss repeatedly refuses to
pay his wages.
Although Ali is played beautifully by Tripathi,
apparently he wasn't the original choice for
the role.
That was actually Filipino actor Carlo Aquino,
who the show's creator invited to audition
after seeing him in a Filipino movie.
But despite being offered the part of Ali,
sadly for Aquino, Covid-19 restrictions prevented
him from travelling to Korea for the shoot.
So, the production looked to foreign performers
already in the country which is how Indian
actor Tripathi, who moved there 11 years ago,
got his chance to impress the team with his
'emotional acting' and fluency in Korean.
Three auditions later, Tripathi got his big
breakthrough and went on to capture the hearts
of millions with his take on the kind and
selfless Ali, leaving many of us in crying
our eyes out during his heart-rending final
scenes.
By the way, another Filipino actor Christian
Lagahit also auditioned for Ali, but while
his acting was good, they were worried he
wasn't fluent enough in Korean.
He did still end up in the show though, as
Player 276, who you can spot taking part in
the tug-of-war on Gi-hun's team.
As if having to play and win kids' game to
stay alive wasn't bad enough, the players
also have to contend with the murderous bully
Deok-su, and his gang including con-artist
Mi-nyeo, who interestingly enough weren't
in the original script for Squid Game.
According to the show's creator, he added
them to the Netflix series as he wanted "a
villain character to escalate conflict".
In the initial movie script, there was no
sign of policeman Jun-ho who, in the series,
poses as a worker to infiltrate the games
and find his missing brother.
Jun-ho ends up being a crucial part of the
story as he gives viewers a backstage pass
to life behind the scenes for both the workers
and the VIPs.
Thank goodness, then, that the show's creator
was able to add his character and storyline
once he had lots of extra screen-time to play
with adapting his film idea for TV.
Combined with its eye-catching artwork, Squid
Game is such an attention-grabbing title for
the show that it's hard to imagine anyone
ever thinking of calling it anything else!
But in 2019, when Netflix first announced
they were producing the series, it had a totally
different name.
Back then, it was called 'Round Six', after
the number of games played.
According to Minyoung Kim, the Netflix executive
for the region,
that name came about because they wanted the
show to appeal to audiences everywhere and
"were worried" not enough people would get
the title 'Squid Game'
What an odd name
as even in Korea, where it's a real children's
game, apparently it's not well-known to every
generation.
So, initially, they thought the more general
name 'Round Six' would help people understand
what the series was about.
Fortunately, the writer-director later steered
them back to his original title as "it's a
unique show and [that] game is the essence
[of it]".
Even worse than a title change for many people
though, would have been if the show had never
been made!
And, for a long time, that was a very real
probability as all the Korean studios that
creator Hwang pitched his idea to, back in
2008/09, thought the whole concept was "too
grotesque and unrealistic".
So, finding investors and actors for his script,
which at the time was for a two-hour movie,
proved impossible.
A decade later, however, the show's writer-director
says that,
"sadly, the world has changed [into a place]
where such an unbelievable survival story
fits well",
and he added that some elements even seem
realistic now given so many people are interested
in fast money-making schemes, and [on top
of] that, the pandemic has "exacerbated the
disparity between rich and poor".
In fact, he actually came up with the original
idea, after the global financial crisis of
2008, when three generations of his own family
were struggling for money and living on loans
after his mother retired and a film he was
working on fell through.
Indeed, things were so bad that at one point
"he had to stop writing the script" as he
needed to sell his laptop for cash.
A breakthrough came, though, in 2018 when
he took his idea to Netflix who'd just recently
opened an office in Seoul and they snapped
up the project, suggesting they "[work] together
to turn it into a series", as they felt there
was much more to the story than could be contained
in one movie.
A lot of hard work later and Squid Game became
South Korea's first series to reach Netflix's
number one spot in the US and around the world.
And the show's just full of incredible details
in the set design plus tons of sneaky easter
eggs and foreshadowing for all the characters,
which I discuss in lots more depth in my Things
You Missed video.
Tap here to watch that or follow the link
in the video description.
So, are there any games or things you'd like
to see in Season 2 of Squid Game?
Let me know in the comments below.
And if you enjoyed this, then a thumbs-up
and a share are hugely appreciated.
Tap left for my full Squid Game playlist including
amazing improvised moments that changed the
show.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!